[Music]
okay
so this is my spoiler review of the new
thriller
the rental this is dave franco's
directorial debut
he also wrote the screenplay with joe
swanberg this is a film with four
main players in it that has a really
strong cast in dan stevens allison brie
jeremy allen white
and sheila bond with some incredible dog
acting from reggie
in interviews dave franco has been open
about that this film was inspired
by his fear of airbnbs and rentals of
homes that are just
given to you by strangers that you just
trust from certain good reviews he has a
fear he talks about about privacy in
these situations and that like we see in
the film any little thing that could be
going on like a little tiny camera and a
shower
you never know so that's where the
horror of this film
is set and the goal of it is to make you
scared of that
thought of someone watching you and just
you trusting
a stranger so easily where the strength
in the film comes with characters and
conflict is actually in the theme of
adultery
and lying and how the actions of two
people affects the whole group and it
becomes a snowball effect
and that when you lie it quickly leads
to another lie and never stops
and everyone ends up paying for it for
this being a directive debut for franco
this is really good
what shows is that he is a man who's
grown up in this industry he's been
around
a lot of big names that he clearly got
mentored from
so you see that right away being his
first film it doesn't feel like that
there's a lot of confidence here and
every camera shot has
purpose you see that from the bat with
the establishing shot of seeing the
cliff
where the water is which will be where
they throw
taylor off later on and where mina will
face her pending doom
and it's interesting because you see
right from the first scene where we see
charlie and mina in this office
partnership
but they're very touchy there's
chemistry there
and you're like whoa when josh comes in
you find out they're brothers and he's
the one actually dating her so franco
does a good job of
kind of keeping you off guard about
what's really going on with this
weird kind of dynamic between these two
brothers and this girl
and they're both clearly in love with
her and then you find out that charlie's
actually married
to allison brie's character and michelle
now it's obviously predictable that
mina and charlie were gonna have an
affair here they're showing you that
writing on the wall from the start
but i think it was purposely so obvious
because
that wasn't supposed to be this surprise
shocking moment that was supposed to
just
develop into a big storyline causing
all these suspenseful events to happen
later on with the killer and opening the
door for the killer schemes to play out
and it also serves to the theme of this
killer kind of
being like the jigsaw killer from the
saw films where
he has some method to his madness but
also has some kind of moral belief here
we kind of get hints at
where he doesn't just kill these people
he wants to expose the bad in them and
before he kills
michelle and josh he wants them to see
the truth so
is there some good to it or is it
actually worse getting to see these
awful truths and then you die
so you get a horrible image of humanity
before you go out so maybe where the
predictability
didn't work as well was actually taylor
the man who is selling the rental home
to them
being such a predictable red herring you
knew from the start he was gonna be the
red herring it would have been too easy
and ridiculous if he ended up being the
bad guy here because they were making it
too obvious at that point
if he was so you just knew as a result
that no way is he the bad guy so it was
i wish they kind of made it a little
more get you to think maybe he actually
is the guy that kind of took away little
suspense
but what worked really well here was
establishing sympathy for the characters
of josh and michelle
especially in the beach scene where
they're walking together observing the
behavior of
charlie and mina and what franco does
good is that he shows you a lot of point
of view perspectives from people
and he sits on a lot of people he lets
the camera
stay one take on somebody's reaction
shots he's more about the reactions and
the actual actions in this film
and i think that worked well to get
inside the character's heads he also
puts little drops of humor in there
which comes from his real-life wife
allison bree who plays michelle
you feel for michelle this whole way
through and she's on a different
schedule than everyone else
and she's having a horrible time because
of it they want to do drugs when she
doesn't and then when she want to do
these drugs
everyone's just out of it another good
humorous moment here is when they
actually first take the drugs and
charlie's dancing with the dog i thought
that was hysterical
and franco really does a good job with
this fog here
starting to add the eeriness to it and
really good staging
and blocking in this scene where we have
this big moment in the hot tub with mina
and
charlie where there's actually just
suspense where you know the cheating is
going to happen
it's a matter of when and they do a good
job with them first just trading using
the jets and then sharing it and then
leading up to this big betrayal
and reggie the dog is so important here
he's not just there to be cute he's a
huge part of the symbolism in this film
that happens because right when the
affair happens in the hot tub he starts
to bark
it's just showing you that that reggie
here is
the symbolism of innocence and is lost
at that moment in our group
and you see the next day after the
affair this is when reggie goes missing
and why a little shot of reggie just
playing with the football is so
important
the next day to then seeing him gone
that little innocent figure
and it pays off in the end because my
favorite moment of the film is actually
at the end when reggie comes back and
he's with the killer and the killer
doesn't kill him he never killed the dog
and he didn't want to in the end because
he was this little innocent guy thought
that was a huge
effective chilling scene and thought out
well and he
purposely selected his point of view
shots well from the killer
it actually is first hinted at when we
see an overhead shot of michelle in bed
and then the big one is when it's really
obvious it's the killer here watching
them
is when he's watching them at the hot
tub having this affair
so his point of view shots are important
because they're not just him scouting
out when he's gonna kill these people
it's him scouting out the right timing
and catching them in their worst moments
that goes to when michelle goes on the
hike with josh and michelle finds out
more about
her husband she didn't know that he's
pretty much a serial cheater
and that hits on that theme where
sometimes we date someone
when they're with somebody else and you
think you're the special one and it's
not going to happen to you but
most of the time people repeat their
behavior and that's what starts to scare
her about her husband and we see
charlie falls into that most unlikable
person here in the movie he is a serial
liar besides just being a serial cheater
when mina finds the camera in the shower
she has a smart decision so just
let's call the cops do the right thing
and
charlie's first reaction is no because
then they're gonna find out about the
affair
so he puts that first it's a selfish
decision that just leads to more chaos
and just lets his killer schemes work
into his play
meena's just as guilty as charlie here
and they're both
fine with covering up the affair even
though
they know doing that is having michelle
and josh be spied on when they're
showering that day it's creepy
and i mean allison brie absolutely kills
it here with the humor i thought another
great scene was her
just when she's on the molly just
teasing taylor with his butt crack that
was a really nice moment it adds relief
throughout this
and it makes you like her more and more
so you feel worse for her as this goes
on where she's so out of the loop and
you see where mina really screws up is
actually where she accuses
taylor of completely being convinced
he's the one who put the camera up there
when he was actually starting to be nice
to her he's saying that he hopes she
actually finds her dog and she kind of
just
lets anger run her better judgment here
and that just starts
a chain of effects where josh thinks
taylor's actually hurting mina
and then his anger comes out that was
hinted at the whole film but you feel
for josh still because he didn't
actually kill this guy and he's
defending mina
thinking something else is going on but
mina's not telling josh the whole
truth here and then he gets screwed over
because this perfectly works to the
killer
where it's cleverly written that the
killer actually goes and
kills taylor himself to really frame
josh and cause even more chaos between
these four people and a big moment
for characters with michelle and charlie
is how opposite they are in the horror
she's realizing more and more about her
husband
how much of really a selfish lying
person he is
and her saying let's call the cops
and he's like no we can get away with
this protect our brother from going to
jail
but michelle's the most genuine here and
she's like i know we can get away with
it i don't want to get away with it i
don't want to live with that but you see
mina and charlie the way they're able to
hold their affair
and hold on to that without saying
anything is the same way they're
ready to lie about this murder so it
does show you that difference in
characters and it works really well
i also really like how franco revealed
to michelle's character the shower
footage
that as michelle were thinking the
shower's on
in one shower and then she checks the
other shower but then she finds the
footage on the tv i thought that was
really clever
and once she sees this footage this is
where we first see the killer's
masked face and the michael myers show
begins i thought it was
funny the scene where they're kind of
throwing this
rock to push taylor into the ocean
because they messed up on the original
throw of his body
but it dragged a little bit here for the
sake of humor that maybe
wasn't even necessary and that would be
my only critique in the debut
of franco's film is i think his pacing
is a little
wonky and can get a little more tighter
and pick up a little quicker
a lot of thrillers and horrors that come
out now like doing this thing where
halfway through in the movie things pick
up and that's fine you want to earn to
get to that
quicker pace and build up your
characters but i do think
still really slow up parts before that
and they gotta wind it up a little
earlier but that's me nitpicking and
that's not something that i think was
too detrimental to the film i do wish
having to wait for big payoff with the
kills you want clever kills in an
audience you've seen a lot of slashers
before you've seen people chasing people
down so you want the big payoff and the
actual killing
i only think we got one of those which
was with mina i thought it was
really cool how she ended up dying
running off the cliff
and threw the fog so it spoke volumes it
connected to her character well
and it was a certain karma to it that's
why i wish charlie who's the most
unlikable hero got the best death and it
was just him getting hit by a hammer
as the other two characters did as well
so that was a little
bland and could have been more creative
and there was a weird head-scratching
moment
that was just strange to me i did not
understand was when
josh actually gets through this door
with mina
and they're looking through the boxes
and josh just finds these pictures
and we as the audience don't see them
clearly we don't really know what he saw
there
i mean is like what are those and he's
like jesus you don't want to know
okay that's a weird line to throw in
there because we never get an answer on
that what was the point of that that was
strange and why wouldn't he tell mina
but worked effectively emotionally in
the scene was josh hugging her saying
he's a piece of crap to meena
and you feel for josh again because this
is a big moment mina could have been
honest with him about the affair and
maybe
made him feel a little better about
himself but she doesn't and he doesn't
know about the affair which is a vital
info to all this and he doesn't know
that he actually didn't kill
taylor so it works to serve that purpose
of this
theme about how actions of just two
people affect the whole group and bad
decisions
and that mina and charlie just keep
repeating these mistakes of lying so
after
the killer ends up killing the four main
players here
i like the creepy moment of him looking
in the mirror with his mask on and like
i said before my favorite moment was a
dog running into the killer
clearly franco did not want to show you
the face of the killer because he wants
to keep that eeriness
and truth to it that killers like this
that
just peeping tom people and
kill them from afar you never see their
face so he wants to keep that effect to
make you think about it
later on after watching the film so i
think that was actually a smart choice
might frustrate some viewers though
because in movies like this you kind of
want some kind of twist or explanation
of to who this killer was so it's a
tough sell but i understand it to work
with the theme of this movie
and franco clearly wants to show in this
last montage
when we're seeing him go to different
rental places the killer how easy it is
for him to set something like this up
and how it can happen so much
and just a warning to us as an audience
to really be careful
trusting strangers to be the people
housing you so to me this is a really
excellent directorial debut
it feels like if you look at great
directors in the past who've made great
films it feels like a lot of their
debuts in the sense of there's a lot of
potential here
for some greatness to come in his future
films i think that's gonna happen
i think this is really really good for a
first film it's a solid thriller it has
great acting the performances shine
and it has some really good suspense in
which you want a thriller towards the
end
i just think the pacing was a little off
and that could be worked on in his
future films but thematically it sets a
goal
it accomplished its goal and you're
invested the whole time and it really is
few and far between with thrillers and
horrors right now to have such
an edge of your seat ending so i thought
that worked really well so i'm giving
this one an
8.7 let me know what you thought of it
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts
also i got to interview jeremy allen
white himself
who plays josh in this film and you
probably know him as lip gallagher from
shameless it was a really fun
chat i got with him so please check that
out be linked below and please make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss one of my
reviews or celebrity interviews
and please follow me at stevebarley1 on
twitter instagram for more of me and
i'll see you next time